En este video vamos a hacer un par de ejemplos
relacionados con rectas paralelas y perpendiculares.
Tenemos entonces que las rectas pueden ser,
paralelas o perpendiculares y por supuesto,
hay rectas que entre sí no son ni paralelas,
ni perpendiculares.
Y a manera de revisión recordemos que, las
rectas paralelas nunca se intersectan.
Dibujemos aquí uno ejes, si estos son mis
ejes coordenados, este es mi eje "x" y este es mi eje "y".
Si inicialmente tenemos una recta,
como esta en magenta.
Voy a dibujar una recta paralela.
Hela aquí. Estas dos rectas, son diferentes, pero al ser paralelas tienen la misma pendiente,
si esta recta se mueve en "x" una cierta cantidad
y tiene esta razón de cambio de "y" con respecto
a "x", esta recta de acá abajo va a tener
la misma razón de cambio de "y" con respecto
a "x", por eso, nunca se intersectan.
Así es que tienen la misma... misma pendiente...
las rectas paralelas tienen la misma pendiente.
Las rectas perpendiculares bajo cierta perspectiva
son lo contrario, si esta es una recta dada,
una recta perpendicular, no tan solo intersecta
esa recta, sino que lo hace formando un ángulo recto.
Este ángulo de aquí, es un ángulo de 90 grados.
Ahora, no lo voy a probar aquí, lo voy a hacer en la sección de álgebra lineal,
pero se puede probar, que si dos rectas son perpendiculares...pongamos
que esta recta tiene una pendiente de "m",
entonces la recta perpendicular...
la recta perpendicular a una recta con pendiente "m"
va a tener una pendiente que es igual a -1
entre "m", estas dos pendientes son recíprocas
y de signo contrario.
Bien, ahora conociendo esto veamos algunas rectas,
para determinar si son paralelas
o perpendiculares o ninguna de las dos.
Para lo cual tendremos que checar las pendientes.
Veamos, una recta pasa por los puntos 4, -3 y -8, 0;
otra recta... otra recta, pasa por los punto
-1, -1 y -2, 6.
Calculemos las pendientes de estas dos rectas.
Haré primero ésta en color rosa.
Entonces la pendiente de esa primera recta
que voy a llamar pendiente 1, va a ser igual...
voy a tomar éste como el punto final, entonces sería,
-3 menos 0, el avance en "y", -3 menos 0,
sobre 4 menos -8...
4 menos -8... esto va a ser igual, -3 menos 0 es -3,
y 4 menos -8 es 4 más 8, que es igual a 12 y
esto es igual a -1/4.
Dividimos entre 3 numerador y denominador
para obtener -1/4.
Esa es la pendiente de la primera recta.
Calculemos la pendiente de la segunda recta.
Entonces la pendiente 2, es igual... vamos
a tomar éste como el punto final,
sería -1 menos 6 entre -1 menos -2... -1 menos -2,
esto es igual a -1 menos 6 es igual a -7,
y el denominador es -1 más 2, menos por menos
es más, -1 más 2 es igual a 1.
Esta pendiente es entonces -7. Comparando
las pendientes ahora, vemos que no son iguales,
por lo cual no son paralelas las rectas, y
tampoco son recíprocas de signo contrario,
así que no son ni paralelas ni perpendiculares,
es decir, ninguna de las dos.
Las dos rectas se intersectan, pero no van
a formar un ángulo de 90 grados en la intersección.
Hagamos un par de ejemplos más.
Aquí tenemos, de nueva cuenta,
una recta que pasa por estos puntos y otra recta que
pasa por estos otros puntos.
Encontremos sus pendientes.
Tenemos entonces que la pendiente de la recta en verde, le voy a llamar "m1".
La pendiente de la recta en verde es "m1", va a ser, voy a tomar este como punto final,
entonces sería el avance en "y"
que sería -2 menos 14, entre...
para esta coordenada en "y"
ésta es la "x" que le corresponde...
1 menos -3, esto es igual, -2 menos 14 es
igual a -16 y 1 menos -3, es igual a 1 más 3,
que es igual a 4, esto es igual a -4.
Ahora, para la segunda recta, la pendiente 2,
que le voy a llamar "m2" es igual el avance
en "y" que sería 5 menos -3... 5 menos -3,
dividido entre el avance en
"x" que es -2 menos 0...
-2 menos 0, esto es igual, 5 menos -3, es 5 más 3 que es igual a 8, dividido entre -2 menos 0,
que es igual a -2, 8 entre -2 es igual a -4.
Así que las dos pendientes son iguales y
estas rectas son paralelas.
Estas rectas son paralelas, tienen pendientes
iguales, te invito a que encuentres la ecuación
de las dos rectas,
grafiques las rectas y puedas verificar visualmente que las rectas son paralelas.
Hagamos ahora este ejemplo.
Y de nueva cuenta, es un ejemplo en el cual
tenemos que calcular pendientes.
Calculemos la pendiente de esta recta.
Le vamos a llamar la pendiente de la recta 1, "m1",
veamos entonces el avance en "y" que sería 3 menos -3... 3 menos -3, dividido entre 3 menos -6,
esto es igual a 3 más 3 igual a 6, dividido entre 3 más 6 igual a 9, 6/9 ó 2/3.
Veamos ahora la pendiente de la segunda recta...
la pendiente de la segunda recta que denominaremos
"m2" es igual al avance en "y" que sería
-8 menos 4 dividido entre 2 menos -6...
2 menos -6, esto es igual -8 menos 4 = -12,
dividido entre 2 menos -6, menos por menos es más,
esto es igual a 2 más 6 = 8, entonces esta pendiente es -12/8 ó simplificando esto es igual a -3/2.
Notemos entonces que estas pendientes tienen signo contrario y sus valores son recíprocos.
Veamos esto, si hacemos -1 entre 2/3 esto es igual a -1 que multiplica a 3/2 y esto es igual a -3/2.
Estos dos números son de signo contrario
y son recíprocos, si agarras un número,
le cambias el signo e inviertes numerador
y denominador, obtienes el otro número.
Así es que estas rectas son perpendiculares...
perpendiculares...
Y nuevamente te invito a que encuentres las
ecuaciones de las rectas, ya tienes aquí
las pendientes, las grafiques y verifiques
visualmente que las rectas son perpendiculares.
Hagamos uno más.
Encuentra la ecuación de la recta perpendicular a "y" igual a -2/5 de "x" menos 3 que pasa por el punto 2, 8.
Entonces lo primero que nos dice es que es
perpendicular a esta recta.
Y esto, ¿qué quiere decir?
Si es perpendicular a esta recta,
la pendiente tiene que ser el recíproco
de -2/5 con signo contrario,
así es que la pendiente de la recta perpendicular tiene que ser... lo voy a hacer con otro color...
Si es perpendicular a esta recta, su pendiente
tiene que ser el recíproco de -2/5 con signo contrario.
Así es que el recíproco de 2/5 es 5/2 y en vez de ser negativa va a ser positiva.
Así es que esto es el recíproco de signo contrario de -2/5, ¿de acuerdo?
Cambias el signo negativo, se hace positivo, intercambias 2/5 y obtienes 5/2.
Así es que éste tiene que ser el valor de la pendiente.
Y ahora, para obtener la ecuación de la recta,
ya conocemos la pendiente y sabemos que pasa
por este punto, usemos la forma punto pendiente.
Entonces la ecuación sería "y" menos 8,
este punto tiene que estar en la recta
y la coordenada en "y" de ese punto es 8, "y" menos
8 es igual a la pendiente que es 5/2
que multiplica a "x" menos 2,
que es la coordenada en "x" cuando "y" vale 8.
Y esta es la ecuación de la recta en forma
punto pendiente,
si la queremos en forma pendiente ordenada, tenemos que hacer algunas manipulaciones alebraicas.
Entonces ¿qué tenemos?
Del lado izquierdo es "y" menos 8 y del lado
derecho vamos a distribuir 5/2.
Sería entonces 5/2 de "x" menos 5/2 por 2,
los 2 se cancelan y nos queda 5.
Ahora, sumando 8 a ambos lados de la ecuación,
nos resulta, "y" es igual a 5/2 de "x",
8 menos 5 es igual a 3,
tenemos ya la ecuación
de la recta y así hemos concluido.